[Musique]
face à la première
bienvenue dans face à la première notre
émission politique au sens large
l'émission politique hebdomadaire
diffusée le vendredi à 14 ans sur notre
site internet et le dimanche en radio à
12h on vive le carnaval c'est le thème
de notre émission avec aujourd'hui 2
spécialistes de la question à ma droite
dans le studio line rosberg
bonjour à nabeul oui bonjour bonjour à
tous les auditeurs vous êtes directrice
des musées de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique et donc vous
êtes quelque sorte celle qui chapeaute
tout l'activité des musées vivants 2 sur
l'échelle du territoire c'est bien ça
oui mais avec aussi une bonne équipe
d'ailleurs absolue des collaborateurs et
vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur la
carnaval sa jeunesse dans l'histoire
ainsi que cela carnaval de saint pierre
davant 1912 donc nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler puis de parler également
du carnaval d'aujourd'hui voire même de
demain avec notre autre invité avec
lequel vous dit allô gré ils vont la
morandière bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation de vous êtes le chef de
la mission carnaval de la ville de fort
de france et à ses origines parce que
céline ne va en ville d outre-mer ou de
france ou même de martinique à avoir une
émission spécifiquement dédié à cette
manifestation
je crois effectivement c'était un choix
politique au sens noble du terme donc
c'était avec monsieur tchimou et en même
temps ça répondait à une préoccupation
des acteurs du carnaval d'abord un
interlocuteur bardon pour un petit peu
élargir ou faire conscience delà de la
dimension carnaval et je crois que cet
attentat était espéré attendu donc là je
suis en place les choses se passent le
mieux en mieux donc ça veut dire en fait
nous sommes sur fort de france
mais nous sommes pas en vase clos ça on
a des relations avec l'ensemble du
territoire martinique et je crois qu'ils
s'expriment à fort de france
parce qu'on al'impression ville à
l'extérieur vous allez me démentir le
cas échéant que le carnaval c'est la
sphère de plusieurs communes de
plaisance sociation différents
disparates et qui ne s'entendent pas
forcément qu'ils ont du mal à s'entendre
non parce que depuis qu'ils ont nés là
vous voyez il ya des manifestations qui
se passe dans une commune et pas dans
une autre
on est arrivé à un consensus pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de grandes manifestations en
même temps en fait les acteurs sont les
mêmes ce serait difficile de
démultiplier donc ce consensus là existe
c'est vrai que mon des communes aussi de
l'animation carnaval il n'y a pas qu'au
lieu que la ville mais à ce niveau là je
crois que les choses se déroulent de
l'entente est là et les choses se passe
de mieux en mieux
alors est-ce que le carnaval tels que
l'on la vie aujourd'hui doit être ou est
devenu est devenu un spectacle au
détriment de son caractère j'allais dire
populaire spontané même si ce caractère
populaire et spontané a toujours je
pense le contrôle de volume 11 mai a
toujours été un gars un encadré organisé
depuis l'origine effectivement c'est
vrai que notre carnaval puisque il
existe dès le xviiie siècle et on peut
dire
à saint pierre le carnaval c'est la
liesse populaire avant tout par exemple
il avait il a vraiment pris corps à la
fin du 19ème à saint pierre sous la
forme de vie d un de grands vides et
avec des orchestres et puisqu'il y avait
des bandes rivales
il y avait même des associations qui se
créent y est spécifiquement pour le
carnaval par exemple il y avait deux
associations de femmes en 1888 on compte
l'association féminine qui s'appelle les
sans souffrance et l'autre qui s'appelle
les intrépides est vraiment c'était de
deux sociétés un peu rival et qui
justement au travers de leurs roquettes
oui aussi c'étaient des orchestres un
petit peu rivaux donc cours elles vidées
dans les rues de saint pierre dont il y
a toujours eu cet aspect populaire alors
pour l'aspect spectacle alors on peut
dire entre guillemets qu'il y avait un
peu carnaval des riches qu'en aval des
pauvres puisque à saint pierre la bonne
bourgeoisie aussi voulait être dans la
rue tout comme les békés un donc et là
c'était sur une pelouse du stade qui
sont différents des geeks et des
planteurs oui parce que les personnes de
couleur
les mules à dix on les lui la trêve donc
ils avaient aussi leur carnaval qui
était avec des costumes un peu plus
somptueux et il y avait ce qu'on appelle
la cavalcade à saint pierre qui était
sur des chevaux et puis avec des déchets
entre guillemets des chars fleuris avec
pierrot et colombine en fait des masques
des costumes plus européanisée un
européen d'ailleurs et puis à côté il y
avait donc la liesse la liesse populaire
donc les deux les deux prouver à exister
mais c'est encore là car aujourd'hui
d'après oui on améliore de manière
générale pas fort de france seulement
puisque vont sillonner toute la
martinique du carnaval après carnaval
les deux aspects prévalent encore
aujourd'hui la plupart l'accord
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'en même temps il
ya des associations qui secret et puis
aussi à cette particularité où il ya
parfois des quartiers qui se rassemblent
pour le colloque l'occasion et qui vont
en ville
donc il ya aussi c'est toute cette
dimension là et cette dimension
populaire
et aussi aussi par rapport aux thèmes de
couleurs où chaque jour permet à tout un
chacun d'y être donc on a encore cette
dimension populaire même si il y à des
groupes des associations qui veulent
faire du clinquant mais ça aussi ça
existe toujours
alors line trois buts dans un entretien
à nos confrères de france antilles il ya
juste un an le 24 février 2017 vous
disiez entre autres que notre carnaval
ne devienne pas un carnaval spectacle
pourquoi c'est une crainte chez vous oui
parce que moi on fait ça nous regarde
que moi
moi je pense que c'est un aspect de
notre patrimoine immatériel que nous ne
devons pas perdre
c'est pas parce que effectivement que ce
soit à rio que ce soit à trinidad
il y à cette dimension un peu économique
c'est vrai que ça attire beaucoup de
gens mais on peut tout à fait faire les
2 1 on peut tout à fait faire les deux
c'est à dire que moi je trouve qu'il
faut effectivement que l'on aide ces
associations d'ailleurs elles peuvent se
mutualiser et il peut avoir une
véritable économie de carnaval chez nous
où justement faire des costumes etc
mais à côté de ça et c'est ce que je
trouve extraordinaire en martinique et
que j'adore aussi c'est que les
associations qui se dé qui ont des très
beaux déguisements n'empêche pas
n'empêche pas aux gens qui veulent
participer à leur groupe d'y venir
c'est à dire qu'ils sont effectivement
devant mais derrière par exemple on voit
les joueurs qui peuvent intégrer moi
j'étais à n'importe quel groupe et je
trouve ça formidable
tandisque par exemple en guadeloupe vous
n'avez pas le droit d'entrer dans dans
le parce qu'il ya une cotisation à payer
parce qu'ils défilent et c est cet
aspect là il faut qu'on le maintienne
il voit la mort en dire je me retourne
vers vous en citant à nouveau nos
confrères de france inter en juillet
dernier vous disiez que
comme plus tôt vous insistiez le public
que la population à une sorte de
concours d'idées d'appel à idées pour
choisir le thème des éditions 2018 nous
y sommes et 2019 l'année prochaine
est-ce que cet appel a été entendu comme
vous l'espériez cet appel a été entendu
effectivement nous avons eu des hauts
nouveau tour alors nous avons tant que
ça en deux phases la première phase on a
demandé aujourd'hui de faire des
propositions de manière générale donc on
a eu des autos dans ces réponses nous
avons choisi dix jeunes ont encore
demandé de choisir parmi les dix les
deux qui seront retenus il sort de
référendum c'est le référendum parce
qu'en fait je suis d'accord pour dire
que c'est notre carnaval c'est à dire
que même s'il y avait des organisations
qui mettent en place l'organisation il
faut pas qu'elle se coupe des véritables
acteurs et là ils ont proposé deux
thèmes donc en 2018 on a un monde
féerique et ils ont surtout rajouter
dans un monde apaisé
donc on n'a pas obtenu sa mère de free
et puis pour 2019 c'est gigantesque et
carnaval en fait l'idée c'est de
toujours garder notre dimension carnaval
est semée visible de plus loin parce
qu'on a un carnaval qui est assez bas
est bon au niveau de la dalle a donc su
garder ce que nous avons à nous donner
une ampleur plus plus gigantesques
vasques aller au niveau de la rouille a
pas de deux qu'est ce que vous appelez
donner plus de hauteur en fait au niveau
des volumes d'accord au niveau des
volumes danser on regarde mais même
bienvenu un personnage mais les faire de
manière plus spectaculaire tout en
gardant notre avance a dit qu'en fait
c'est pas de partir dans n'importe quoi
mais nous avons un stock il faut le
garder mais ça c'est pour le carnaval de
forme face avec en fait on fait la
proposition la copie bon on a bien vu
que la proposition du carnaval de
fort-de-france a été repris pour la pole
à maintenir donc tant mieux puisque
quand on regarde à fort de france il y à
l'ensemble de la matinée qui vient fort
de france
ceci dit le thème n'est pas quelque
chose de rédhibitoire c'est une
proposition qui est faite et chacun est
libre de choisir dans ce canevas ou de
la dola vous dites que le fondeur
français aujourd'hui
l'endroit où tous les carnavaliers vont
converger ce sera encore le cas ce
dimanche gras mais s'il ya qu à la
parade du sud il ya eu déjà la parade du
nom dont qui a dévidé des initiatives un
peu partout ceci n'empêche pas ceux là
n'ont absolument pas seulement parce que
bon au niveau de photos anciennes
contenance mais s'il y a des dépenses
qu'il ya toujours eu des carnavals
ailleurs plus de certains ya toujours eu
du canada et donc c'est la communication
qui fait qu'on a cette information mais
bon ceci n'empêche pas cela alors si
fort de france et non pas le centre du
monde du carnaval de la technique en
tout cas là où un lieu de convergence
depuis quelques années il n'a pas tout
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
n'est ce pas là une rose buzz puisque en
fait si la sphère de saint pierre en
deux temps ah oui tout à fait au départ
saint-pierre donc des jeux disait le
xviie siècle on retrouve la première
notion de carnaval de 1722 un bon alors
effectivement 700 m2 et au delà c'est
tout oui on trouve la première mention
alors effectivement dans l'histoire du
carnaval
il y a eu aussi beaucoup d'interdits
attendez-vous la première manche au
stade là premier enfant ou ce maudit 722
c'est le carnaval mais que comment s'est
organisée à cette époque terrible oui je
pense que il y avait les esclaves qui
participait mais beaucoup aussi les
européens
pourquoi parce que le carnaval c'est une
très très très grosse tradition
européenne depuis le moyen âge est donc
moi et sachant que la colonisation
martiniquaise c'est fait avec des gens
qui venaient peut-être de pratiquement
de toute la france donc ces personnes
ont apporté aussi leurs traditions en
martinique
la preuve c'est qu'il y a encore des
carnavals européen qui subsiste le
carnaval de nice
le carnaval de dunkerque qui ressemble
beaucoup au nôtre avec des vis d epuis
le monde à l'envers c'est à dire les
hommes en femmes les femmes en sommes
donc
donc si vous voulez cette tradition
carnavalesque existait depuis le moyen
âge en france donc c'est vrai que saint
pierre
il y avait donc effectivement le
carnaval des esclaves
pourquoi parce que les esclaves étaient
souvent regroupés en société on appelait
ça des convois il y avait
à une reine cavaliers d'honneur et c'est
une bannière un orchestre et il pouvait
organiser dès ce qu'on appelle des
l'époque et surtout ils
pouvaient aussi organiser des soirées
dans son petit stand un carnaval
autorisé un carnavaleux
j'ai remis à m cd c'est un carnaval
autorisé mais souvent en fonction des
événements politiques en fonction de
l'atmosphère il y a eu pour beaucoup
d'interdits aussi c'est à dire que dans
les journaux officiels dans le bulletin
officiel de martinique on voit par
exemple en 1700 jouera plus en 10 13 20
17 par exemple on voit qu'il est
interdit de porter des masques
pourquoi parce que on avait toujours
peur de sédition de déco les esclaves se
réunissaient voilà un peu subversif
voilà parce que par exemple à saint
pierre au xviiie siècle et on avait
compté à fort de france ils ont compté à
peu près 10 17 sociétés d'esclaves 17
convoi mais aussi il y en avait autant à
à saint pierre fait fort de france 17 17
à côté de ça il y avait les esclaves qui
se réunissaient par ethnie alors on
avait les congolais oui ça c'est le
début de notre cas puisque effectivement
après juste même après même après
l'interdiction de la traite
on avait des on pouvait retrouver des
esclaves de même ethnie alors les
sociétés d'ailleurs avaient des noms
assez extraordinaire c'était la société
de la rose la société de l'oeillet la
société du jasmin trame du jasmin et on
retrouve encore c'est noah 5 lui si il y
à la fête encore de la société de la
rose à sainte lucie et il se fait
beaucoup de ces 6es société aussi était
un peu rival
alors donc là vous du groupe
je vous révéler quelque chose qui n'est
acquis assez méconnue la morandière
c'est que les esclaves ou pouvait
célébrer le carnaval mais sous réserve
que celui-ci soit contrôlée si vous
veillez bien sont les bêtes parce que
l'ordre colonial l'ordre esclavagiste
est extrêmement rigide de parme origines
mais on trouve même dans un récit je
pense que ça doit être gagnée de
cassagnac qui raconte qu' il y a eu un
carnaval d'esclaves noirs et ils avaient
payé un aux caisses blanc pour pouvoir
animer ce carnaval
1 ce bal c'était un bal de carnaval et
il y avait même nos casques blancs et
les maîtres pouvaient participer il y a
eu des soirées dansantes rouler mm on
peut se mêler aux esclaves c'étaient des
choses un peu ramé ça existait quand
même ce qui se passe à saint pierre et
dans une moindre mesure à froid ya loi
fort de france et se passe-t-il dans les
autres communes at on y attend
connaissance de traces de carnaval
d'ailleurs durant la période esclavage
comme moi je pense peut-être parce que
on dit car on avait recensé les sociétés
de fort-de-france et de saint pierre
mais je pense que dans certaines
paroisses il pouvait avoir des
manifestations carnavalesques ne
serait-ce que encore une tradition
héritée
des européens je sais mon témoin j'ai
connu ça petit qu'il y avait des gens
qui se déguisent est régulièrement
chaque dimanche et qui passaient de
maison malmaison réclamer de l'argent ça
c'est tout à fait une tradition de
d'ailleurs les enfants avaient très peur
parce qu'il courait après les efforts et
qu'ils resteront cool man là derrière le
masque est et et puis mais je pense et
moi j'ai connu sa petite même s'ils n'y
avaient pas spécialement et ça se
passait depuis les oies parce que nos
traditions carnavalesques commençait à
partir des rois dont ça se passait je
pense peut-être pas d'ego car la veille
mais ça se passait aussi
donc est ce que l'on peut dire je
demande aussi un monsieur la morandière
que cette tradition même si elles
méconnu un peu ignoré parce que entre
temps il ya eu l'éruption de 1902 et
d'autres évènements nous y reviendront
peut-être tout à l'heure le tremblement
de terre à fort de france qui a fait que
le début du carnaval a été reporté de
quelques jours
est-ce que nous sommes dépositaires de
toute cette tradition parce que on fait
comme si en technique
nous avons toujours eu ce carnaval je le
dis aux d'un objet non c'est beaucoup
dire
en tout cas de notre patrimoine culturel
c'est vrai que quelque part on voit bien
depuis la naissance du carnaval est en
même temps je suis tenté de dire que le
carnaval à quelque part a été fondateur
de la nation puisque on reparle de
convois donc ça veut dire que au delà
maintenant le carnaval a pris une
connotation qui est plus ou moins
festives ou bon mais si on remonte un
petit peu dans l'histoire les esclaves
avaient cette fenêtre d'expression et ça
permettait en même temps ces esclaves
l'adepte eux-mêmes ne serait ce qu'au
moment donc ça veut dire que la
trasmission été faite de cette manière
là aussi donc au niveau du carnaval oui
mais c'est ce que ce gène qui s'est
transmis de génération en génération je
crois qu'on l'a toujours maintenant il
faut faire attention pour que l'une de
garder et surtout donner du sens mais
quel sens pourrait en donner
parce que si c'était ça n'était pas
aujourd'hui comme vous étiez le carnaval
est plutôt festif distractif mais ce
n'était pas forcément le cas à ses tout
débuts n'est ce pas les grosses bottes
peut-être une fête mais il y avait quand
même une signification
oui si on veut m'en fais cet essai test
et festif un non non je pense que
l'aspect festif a toujours été là mais
je veux aussi dire que il y a eu chez
nous aussi il faut pas oublier quand
même notre ascendance africaine parce
que nous avons aussi si vous voulez une
comment dire des références à certaines
certains masques en afrique il y avait
des fêtes où on permettait par exemple
de 2 de porter des masques dans certains
dans certaines dans certaines tribus je
pense aux urbains où il y avait les
fameux masques gèlèdé quelques légers
orient voilà voilà exactement
donc il y avait aussi cette tradition
africaine qui se retrouvaient oui le
voilà donc il y avait aussi faut pas
oublier donc c'est tout un métissage est
si vous voulez de comment dire de
pratique et que ce soit européennes ou
africaines qui se retrouvaient en
martinique et ça je crois qu'il faut pas
oublier cet aspect là non plus oui il va
la mort à dire ce que justement cette
tradition du carnaval qui se qui se
perpétue devenu festif aujourd'hui mais
ça ce n'est pas que faire la fête c'est
aussi une fonction sociale de commander
h 2
permettre à chacun de dire ce qu'il
pense de d'oublier quelque pendant
quelques jours les codes sociaux
traditionnels
c'est un moment de licence et un moment
aussi où la satire sociale la satire
politique a très souvent été présent
donc c'est un moment particulièrement
magique si je veux dire absolument mais
ceci dit pour moi le festi ce n'est pas
forcément négatif c'est une forme
d'expression et ce n'est pas forcément
négative et c'est vrai que un moment
donné on disait que le carnaval c'est le
moment où elle en interdit d'interdire
mais ensuite même temps on a eu toujours
cette cette présence qui fait que tout
est autorisé mais tout n'est pas permis
et on a sept cette autorégulation
nous-mêmes qui fait que la limite bon on
peut au niveau des mots au niveau de la
trace grâce et beaucoup de choses mais
en même temps il ya toujours cette
petite sentinelle qui nous dit attention
il ya des limites à ne pas franchir
et je crois que c'est ça et on a un
carnaval qui à mon avis n'est pas si
violent que ça un carnaval où
effectivement chacun s'exprime
on a cette possibilité d'avoir jamais
repartie ovi des abrutis de notes donc
ce moment toutes les barrières tombent
et cette intelligence fait qu' on est
ensemble on fait peuple entre guillemets
ensemble et puis après on va voir donc
et je voulais bien s'y ajouter le rôle
de la chanson dans le carnaval parce
qu'à saint pierre bon c'est vrai que là
ça pouf
c'était quand même très satirique et ça
pouvait être un peu violent
politiquement avec par exemple la
défense calvini folle folle folle ça
c'est fini ça c'est unique époux bien
beau faire à vous connaissez la sphère
du du gendarme lilith vainquit qui
justement comme il avait mis un peu
d'ordre dans la dent entre dean des
dents dans la pègre
enfin bien comme bombes ont fâché les
malfrats un peu les délinquants disons
il se croyait très fort il voulait se
présenter aux élections mais
malheureusement lui a bien tendu un
piège
et ça l'a obligé à démissionner et
lorsque il a démissionné il a embrassé
son sabre et son sabre ont fait et du
coup il ya eu cette chanson satirique
sur le bo fait à
a connu un double sens mais comme d'hab
aujourd'hui est ce que ça veut dire
encore beaucoup de choses parce qu'il ya
eu pendant très longtemps concours de la
chanson créole qui a été instaurée dans
les années 1950 suis auto à fort de
france et qui s'étend du un peu partout
avec moi j'ai comme brasier le montant
par exemple puis le loup à la ville qui
a pris le relais
est ce qu'aujourd'hui encore la chanson
est un vecteur de justement de critique
sociale ou alors d'une peinture de notre
société
on a l'impression qu'elle a appris que
d'autres éléments
une passion sur la chanson ils vont la
morandière non en fait pour qu'on s'y
retrouver surtout les artistes se sont
retrouvés samedi quand on a cette
manière martinique de leucate à
l'audience lundi
quelqu'un qui excellent moment donné
dans de la chanson qui a fait le succès
du canada ça devient un chanteur deux
clans a peur ce chanteur de noël et en
fait je crois que c'est pas une bonne
manière de valoriser ce travail là et
parfois on a aussi tendance à croire que
carnaval si jen s'est passé au lieu de
piau qualifié de bach en aval ou pas
d'ayew passer aux yeux et c'est une
erreur à mon avis parce que il n'ya pas
de chansons de carnaval ya des chansons
qui se sentent pendant le carnaval et
pillé un genre musical donné il faut
absolument pas ce que c'est ccsa
chanteur là qui alimentait la rue et en
même temps c'était une page d'histoire
bouffer à l'industrie du porc quatre
cantons quand on réécoute la chanson ça
fait partie des moments de l'histoire
donc je pense qu'il faudrait que les
chanteurs ou bien les auteurs
compositeurs j'ai pas reviennent à ce
moment là pour permettre à la wii de
reprendre des chansons parce que bon
presse confié qu'on voit maintenant on
reprend les chansons enfantines et puis
on transforme les paroles et puis bon
c'est fait mais ça y est cette
créativité dans cette créativité mais je
crois qu'il faut redonner à cette
chanson là c'est le moment où tout le
monde chante ensemble c'est le seul
moment autour les organes que nous avons
commun la voie en forme et en communion
il faut absolument qu'on retrouve ça va
être aussi fait d'actualité qui est
chanson oui parce qu on a quand même des
deschamps sont vides et qui ont marqué
le loup par exemple qui était
extraordinaire que le show johnny et que
tout le monde reprend encore jusqu'à
présent donc il y a quand même des
chansons on ne peut pas dire que ça
dépend effectivement de la créativité
mais ya quand même des chansons qui
marque et qui sont d'un autre temps
quand même et on ne peut pas dire qu'il
n'y a que des chansons et infantile moi
c'est un fait ce que je veux dire c'est
bon il n'y a pas franchement des
locations de vélos ou les chanteurs
s'investissent comme désormais on a
connu aux rasoirs bon c'est des chansons
qui qui qui reste au niveau de la
période et puis après fameux oui c'est
vrai effectivement vous avez compris que
nous parlons dans le carnaval la face à
la première aujourd'hui avec l'hymne
rosebud directrice des musées de la cité
m
et ils vont la morandière chef de la
mission carnaval de la ville de fort de
france alors le carnaval aujourd'hui et
demain tout à l'heure nous avions
commencé l'émission disant qu' il ne
faut pas qu'il devienne un spectacle et
en même temps c'est un spectacle mais un
défoulement populaire canaliser organisé
mais en même temps cette année donc ce
sont le paradoxe martin qui s'exprime
dans le carnaval mais finalement il ya
des depuis des années il ya des
tentatives de faire en sorte que le
carnaval de vienne un spectacle on parle
mais manquant de le faire maintenant
comme on boit rio avec le sambodrome
bien trinidad si elle examine le protoss
peine de le cantonner dans un endroit
précis pour faire défiler avec des
spectacles de en payant on va arriver à
salé nous mais j'espère de nous je prie
le ciel
non non vraiment il faut que notre
carnaval
non on peut l'organiser on peut
organiser le circuit mais comme on le
fait maintenant avec des interdictions
du centre ville parce qu'effectivement
centre-ville ya quand même des gens qui
habitent il ya des commerces etc
il peut avoir des dérives et au port on
va penser à un fameux mercredi des
cendres
donc moi je pense qu'il faut quand même
qu'il y ait un circuit d'empeaux fort de
france
mais il faut surtout que les gens
puissent défiler librement et comme ils
veulent quoi en fait dans des vide et
tout en étant né en ayant cet aspect
spectacle moi je trouve que bon c'est
vrai qu'actuellement
on a encore des associations qui se
battent un peu et qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de moyens jeu il faut aussi que l'on que
l'on les aides pour le carnaval
parce que ça peut donner lieu à des
commandes et des petites entreprises
d'insertion pour pour faire les habits
moi j'ai vécu à trinidad le la
présentation des costumes
c'est à dire qu'il y a des des
commandites d'aider des gens qui sont
payés pour pouvoir faire les costumes
mais c'était presque une émeute il
fallait que les gens voient les
différents costumes qu'on les décès pour
que les premiers il commença à les
fabriquer et aliot le lendemain du
carnaval on commence tout de suite hein
il ya une véritable économie qui qui
redémarre tout de suite pour le carnaval
de l'année d'après je ne dis pas à koné
à ce stade mais je crois que les
associations qui justement veulent nous
donner de très beaux habits et je crois
qu'il faut les aider je pense à bibas je
pense à et puis il ya toute une
créativité autour du patrimoine
je pense au groupe le madame si chez aux
coupes de madame de biba sans fin et
c'est ce sont vraiment des associations
des animateurs de ces graines il vole à
mentir même question spectacles payants
produit d'appel touristique organisation
j'allais dire plus rationnelle voir
aseptisé comme arrière je suis d'accord
avec madame buzz
il faut que notre carnaval garde cet
aspect populaire cet aspect et
inventivité
par contre on peut avoir cet aspect
touristique parce que bon je suis pas
quand on dit qu'à et qu'en aval
touristique ça veut dire qu'on fait des
choses pour faire plaisir aux touristes
s'il autorise bien partager un moment
avec moi si tout ce que je demande
cette équipe il vient vivent quelque
chose il est avec non il surtout qu'ils
consomment
j'ai pas besoin de son avis vous me dire
que c'est bon c'est pas bon il faut
qu'ils vivent quelque chose de
l'intérieur et ça pour ça il faut garder
notre dimension populaire notre
dimension nous mêmes et ça c'est quoi et
basse bourse il va ailleurs et puis des
spectateurs pas tous les spectateurs
et chez nous il vit quelque chose je
crois que c'est cette se vivent quelque
chose d'acquis doit être ciment qui doit
me faire ça veut dire que nos
martiniquais nous sommes acteurs de
quelque chose et nous ne sommes pas là
en train de faire des choses pour est
bon s'il veut qu'on est les fermes et va
fermer le réussit on n'avait pas là pour
faire plaisir mais fois pour partager
quelque chose et je pense
qu'effectivement ce niveau là la
dimension économique va prendre tout son
sens parce que le carnaval c'est à la
fois la musique et les arts de la rue
c'est le théâtre c'est la couture c'est
la peinture
on retrouve tout ce qui est artistique
au niveau du canada donc si un
organisation qui permet cette expression
la banco mais moi je constate aussi que
les touristes maintenant participe parce
que nous avons des thèmes qui sont très
faciles le mardi gatumba d'hettange le
merdy descente tout le monde est en
blanc et noirs et je constate que de
plus en plus il y à des touristes qui
rentre dans les vides et parce que le le
costume est simple 1 c'est à dire c'est
ce sont des couleurs et je constate que
de plus en plus on a des gens qui rôdent
dans les vides et parce que ça leur est
permis parce qu'ils sont dans le thème
du jouet et et ses 7,7 sait ce qu'il
faut faire ça dit que les gens
participent aussi la nôtre à notre
carnaval
maintenant de la perche monde y croit
tout le monde sera habillé en rouge même
s'il compte pas la vidéo l'après midi
dès le matin les gens qui travaillent
vous livre à paris parce que c'est un
peu particulier en disant ça m'a bien en
rouge et le lendemain nous allons nous
habiller en noir et blanc sans trop
savoir pourquoi forcément on fait comme
souvent parce que c'est la tradition
c'est la coutume allons pourquoi rouge
du mardi gras rhinoise bel et bien parce
qu'en fait le mardi qu'en faisait bon
bain sont pas oublier que carnaval c'est
la période où on mange de la viande et
carême c'est la période où ses maigres
et puis à beaucoup d'interdits et carême
commence 40 jours avant pâques donc
savez la mi-carême d'ailleurs c'est un
moment c'est un temps où l'interdiction
est levée et qu'on peut à nouveau manger
bien manger etc
donc si vous voulez le rouge est
traditionnellement couleurs de du sang
de la viande joue on peut faire bombance
le jour du boeuf leboeuf du mardi gras
qu'en disent ses traditions qui
s'opèrent du monde
oui la beauce le boeuf du mardi gras
effectivement on l'a perdu mais c'était
cette tradition carnet c'est à dire on
pouvait manger au moyen âge de la viande
et ça s'est perpétuée petit peu de petit
à petit et si vous voulez on a cette
couleur rouge que nous avons conservé
pour vous tandis que la lande mais c'est
un jour plus de 2 mais vous allez
trouver car il y a en plus et on a
continué à fort de france la tradition
comme tels du diable de dix ans l'homme
qui sent le mardi gras est ce que là
également on sait qui allie des
recherches c'est pas évident c'est pas
facile de retrouver la jeunesse précise
mais là encore c'est une caractéristique
du carnaval de martinique oui
effectivement parce que on a on a ce
rouge là avec ce sex côté carnet on a le
personnage aussi le diable qui en fait
bon il est happé diable chez nous mais
au départ les réminiscences africaine et
s'appellerait pas diable c'était des
sites et c'était plus une divinité
qu'autre chose ça vienne afrique
oui on a une tradition de la manger de
la viande rouge demander qui vient dé
moyen âge européen
hélas le diable ou le faux diam qui
vient d'afrique section la synthèse
salon donc ce qui fait que on voit bien
que le carnaval a aussi c'est un moment
où on fait rovi passe de tout à l'heure
où y avait cette dimension à cette
origine africaine qui aussi se perpétue
bon c'est vrai que césaire a fait un
travail pour qu'on se réconcilier avec
l'afrique et donc au niveau du camp à
vendre bien que bon tous ces aspects là
sont présents et c'est ce qui s'appelle
donner du sens c'est à dire que on peut
faire des choses parce que nos parents
l'ont fait puis faut que l'on ne le
fassions mais en même temps quand on
connaît le sens ça nous permet mieux de
préserver tout ce qui est ce qui fait
l'originalité et je pense que vous quand
on a l'information c'est mieux que quand
on fait parce que quand on quand on
modifie et on ne sait pas l'origine on
fait autre chose tandis que quand on
connaît l'origine on fait évoluer
et pourtant année après année on voit
que cette tradition en perdurant tout ça
perdure ça bien dit on même si bon je
sais pas si je connais des gens qui
disent que vous voyez vont pas ils vont
pas toucher le diable parce que bon
c'est le diable la pièce d'eau massif et
donc a priori ça n'a rien à voir
oui mais peut-être qu'il faudra
peut-être va dire alors menti comme
mercredi des cendres de même un peu on
est déjà dans l'esprit du carnaval des
sangles une grosse bise là c'est
complètement différent
c'est le début d'une autre période qui
suit est c'est à dire un éveil de carême
et donc on commence à faire le deuil du
carnaval
et là aussi c'est une tradition très
ancienne qui est au moyen âgeuse qu'on
retrouve dans beaucoup beaucoup de lieux
en france avec les générations du du
carnaval parce que dans beaucoup
beaucoup de contres et en france alors
y'a
comment dire un écrivain enfin
chercheurs qui s'appelle van gennep qui
a fait le tour du concert dans le
folklore français et qui justement a
fait 300 cement dans tous les villages
des petits villages oublie tradition qui
pouvaient exister au niveau du carnaval
et on retrouve beaucoup cette tradition
du mercredi des cendres
notamment on bull alors dans certains
petits villages ont brûlés le mannequin
qui représentait le carnaval et dans
d'autres dans d'autres qu'on le noyer
quand le noyer alors chez nous on dit
surtout il faut pas qu'on lui il faut
par contre de loi il faut surtout qu'on
le brûle parce que c'est justement s'il
ya un signe c'est la renaissance mais
j'ai retrouvé un petit texte que je veux
vous dire parce que je les trouvais très
très intéressant des jeux qui dit alors
ça ça ça se passe dans dans la loire
inférieure
alors on dit la veuve de carnaval vous
savez nos fameuses pleureuse la veuve de
carnaval
ah oui c'était pas c'était demain à
toulon la veuve de carnaval qui
parcouraient les rues de toulon dans le
premier quart du 19e siècle
pendant toute la journée du mercredi des
cendres en se désespérant de son deuil
d'une façon comique était un rôle devenu
traditionnel que c'est que je jouais un
certain graille gardien à la préfecture
déguisé en femme avec des vêtements
noirs et escompter de quelques gars mais
ils allaient de porte en porte aux
criaient en criant pauvres enfants ils
n'ont plus de père et il éclatait en
lamentations comique dans tous les
quartiers les commères a conduit à sa
voix ce groupe est autour de lui
échangeant des plaisanteries fort drôle
tandis qu'il leur demande et avec des
sanglots s'il n'avait pas vu carnaval
père de ces malheureuses créatures
qu'elle ne pouvait plus nourrir
vous voyez donc c'est c'est vraiment des
traditions à marseille aussi au bruel on
brûlait le carnaval on brûlait le
mannequin donc vous voyez c'est des
traditions qui chez nous alors c'est
vrai qu'actuellement nous sommes
pratiquement les seuls au monde avec la
guadeloupe et et puis haïti à avoir
cette tradition du mercredi
mais qui existait jusqu'à la fin du
19ème non également il ya la mouradia
quelque chose qui retient qui sera
marquée cette année encore l'un en
revanche il ya moins de monde cette
difficulté à comprendre le sens de ce
mercredi 5 puisque c'est la fin la fin
des festivités
oui effectivement la fin des pertes
évitées et puis c'est aussi le moment
bon oulalalala le couperet va tomber et
ce qui reste sous ses frais ordinaire
c'est que à partir de mercredi le jeudi
tout le monde retrouve son rôle dans la
société
faut dire qu'on a on était enfin b puis
bon les choses continuent comme ça et je
crois qu'effectivement au niveau du
carnaval beaucoup d'endroits le canada
sa lettre le mardi et donc on a on a
cette particularité du mercredi mais il
me semble aussi qu'à saint pierre on le
nouail est le bois bois sous la lapider
peut-être que la fidh
mais je sais que le mercredi des cendres
ont fait pour avoir lu certaines choses
les gens le passé près de la rivière
dont vraisemblablement qu'on voyait le
bois poids parce que la tradition du
mercredi des cendres étaient surtout on
faisait de la danse des tout
ça près de la rivière
oui où l'arrivée vous serez là nous bien
un peu plus loin la rivière des pères
enfin remet alors en parlant de valdes
qui va être comme gage incinérés ce
mercredi déjà une et même pas encore nés
en gestation
alors il y à eux seuls valent qui
reprise qui est qui et comment dirais-je
qui fait l'unanimité au qui peut rien
faire l'unanimité à l'échelle de la
martinique c'est bien sa valeur mais
n'ont cédé qu'en fait on parle plus de
celui de fort-de-france
mais il y a des communes qui continue à
faire lolo le rodéo vannes à l'indoor ça
ça n'a pas sa déco le fort de france n'a
pas n'en fais pas aux autres comme de
faire du c'est que dans notre commune et
ils ont aussi quand on regarde
l'actualité
on voit bien que dans certaines communes
le bas valais bouder donc il y à celui
de fort-de-france qui
capital oblige entre guillemets je
trouve et on en parle plus mais bon ça
m'empêche pas et je dois lui aussi que
haut niveau au niveau du val ça n'a
jamais eu aussi empêché à certaines
associations de faire un va la procédure
quand on regarde le loup qui a manqué d
aider le temps le verbal de l'époque
c'était pas le loup avec effectivement
il ya toujours eu cette possibilité à
d'autres artistes de faire quelque chose
c'est vrai que maintenant avec la
réglementation la sécurité tout ce qu'il
faut maintenant c'est pas aussi évident
de faire un valent donc les
collectivités prennent la la la
possibilité de faire mais ça n'empêche
qu'une association qui a les moyens peut
aussi faire la balle parfaitement à ce
que je voulais dire c'est que le val a
une dimension gigantesque tandis que bon
mais il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle le
bois bois et donc il ya deux choses donc
il ya le petit bleu même qu'elle a qui
paient un truc de division est le plus
souvent
et puis il ya cette à cette gigantesque
quand même chez nous duval et je pense
que c'est la différence entre vaval et
les bois bois jalonnent le bon bah c'est
la marionnette c'est le mannequin qui
doit la division exactement tout à fait
sains et en plus ont ils ont les bouts
elle aussi et ont les boules tous
d'ailleurs
et alors voir qu'est-ce qu'il est quelle
est sa fonction qu'elle est ça c'est
vrai que ça permet c'est le symbole de
ces vers lequel tout le monde convergent
et sur lequel tout le monde doit se
reconnaître
voilà il personnifie en fête le carnaval
c'est c'est la symbolique du carnaval
qui existent pas rien depuis le
moyen-age on le retrouve dans beaucoup
beaucoup de villages alors c'est bien
simple dans certains villages même il
était c'était des gens même qu'on
déguise est il était traîné avec des
liens et pour le boulet le mercredi des
cendres les gens mettaient par exemple
des habits en paille et justement et il
devait se défaire de ses habits en
paille et
et comme brûler il ya eu il ya eu des
fois certains drames donc c'est pour ça
que de plus en plus on a fait tous ces
grands mannequins
oui alors ils vont allumant la
morandière pour le val de fort-de-france
secret est bien gardé ou à peu près ça
nous donnait de scoop d'après vous à
quoi ne va-t-il pas ressembler ouaki
maintenant ceci dit de vapeur qui happe
et animations étudiante elle garde
toujours cette fonction qui avait le
bois bois donc qui est souvent donc
l'idée bon cap il apparaît on est moins
un parent bon c'est souvent la
traduction qui pose problème mais on est
toujours d'accord sur la fonction et la
symbolique
maintenant que je suis pas dans le
secret des dieux donc je sais pas si
vous deviez fait le faire vous le
confectionner quelques contours lui
donneriez vous non on voit bien que dans
l'actualité je me fais un petit peu hot
et au sondage de rue au micro trottoir
beaucoup de gens parler de tcsp et je
crois que bon ça c'est une bonne idée
aussi à ce niveau là ça veut pas dire
que c'est ça mais bon je pense que bon
si si ceux qui organisent on l'aurait du
peuple ça peut être un peu l'oreille du
peuple à 10 ans quelque 168 la panoplie
ça pourrait aussi être up oui ce qui
marque beaucoup
l'actualité ou bien le monsieur koala
qui me voilà voilà
bon ça peut être aussi ça parce que on
est aussi ouvert un sur l'actualité
extérieur alors justement que ça peut
poser des
des accords ont comme disait monsieur la
morandière l'instant ça peut créer des
dégâts quand on peut ne pas traduire la
même chose c'est toujours difficile de
faire l'unanimité évidemment sur cette
initiative un peu personnel même si
c'est un noyau de plusieurs personnes
mais bon c'est pas c'est pas facile de
tomber d'accord sur le bon cheval si je
puis dire ah oui c'est vrai je me
rappelle qu'il ya une année les gens
n'ont pas compris ils ont cherché
longtemps
récemment ils se demandaient mais qui ça
pouvait bien être un bon il ya eu au
moment où il ya eu une phase facebook
que je crois enfin il ya des gagnants
non ça fait déjà deux ans donc si vous
voulez le sait pas tout le temps que le
vaval la nuit fait l'unanimité donc
c'est c'est surtout ça et je me
demandais justement pourquoi à garder le
secret pour enfin moi c'est une petite
idée pourquoi justement ne pas fait
profiter pour faire un sondage au niveau
de la population qui pourrait dire voilà
comment voyez-vous le carnaval cette
année
est ce que c'est possible j'en sais rien
il vole un mendiant qui a déjà fait un
référendum si on a aussi fait
l'expérience pour le vendeur on n'a pas
eu de votre wii j'ai pourtant on a pris
le soin d'eux
vous savez il ya des gens qui
s'expriment beaucoup plus que d'autres
et conquis sous la voie publique
on leur a dit mais c'est vrai que c'est
une responsabilité de faire le bal bon
on n'a pas eu de retour peut-être qu'au
bon c'était trop subite bon en tout cas
on n'a pas eu de retour
il n'empêche que bon il va là bas la
savane bon c'est un petit peu délicat
mais bon bah on va reprendre l'opération
et on va demander à la population va
ceux qui peuvent le faire et on est allé
même plus loin on leur a dit bon fait
une proposition de thème mais en même
temps faites nous une esquisse qu on ne
traitera trahissent pas l'idée on n'a
pas eu d'autre mais ben ça s'est fait en
chocolat parce que j'ai pas entendu
parler de ça du tout fils alex a déjà eu
on a eu on a utilisé le les réseaux les
réseaux sociaux rabbin danger à fait
l'idée va prospérer dans les données de
juillet parce que ça peut être
intéressant c'est alors pour terminer
les missions deux ou trois mots du
carnaval dans la région tout allons nous
évoquions le fait qu' il n'y a pas de
mercredi des cendres pas en tout c'est
une martinique guadeloupe et puis haïti
alors que carnaval est célébré dans
quasiment la plupart totalité des pays
de la caraïbe du nom de l'amérique du
sud de la guyane le surinam qu'il y en a
à colomby que sais-je encore et il se
dit mme line rosbif je parle à
l'historienne que notre le carnaval de
trinidad a beaucoup à voir avec celui de
lens n'est qu'en fait il a été
expérimenté le martiniquais de ses biens
en tout cas été exportées entraînés à
huis mois je pense que c'est vrai parce
qu'à la fin du du xviiie siècle à saint
pierre il y a eu
comment dire
une espèce de répression des mulâtres de
saint pierre d'ailleurs on en a vendu 2
4 sur la place dès la batterie dhainaut
à la batterie des mots et il y a eu un
grand mouvement de départ des mulâtres
martiniquais vers trinidad qui justement
aux frais des terrains c'est à dire que
les les personnes couvert en tant que
personnes de couleur acheter des
propriétés
donc il ya beaucoup de gens de saint
pierre qui sont allés à trinidad
dès la fin du xviiie siècle et qui ont
pu acheter des terres mettre en place
des habitations sucre sucrière et avoir
une certaine aisance son chemin et faire
souche d'ailleurs on a un petr
trinidadien qui est le peintre
trinidadien du 19e qui est le plus
célèbre qui s'appelle 15 1 go et qui
vient d'ailleurs d'une famille
martiniquaise et quand on regarde les
les peintures de casabon du 19e siècle
on constate que l'habit traditionnel
parce qu'ils paient les trinidadienne
c'est le costume martiniquais
c'est le costume jupes chemises de la
martinique et faut pas oublier aussi qu
à trinidad jusqu'à présent dans certains
villages on parle créole on connaît
d'ailleurs certaines chansons de sparrow
ça ça y est et c'est donc ce saut on a
encore du créole martiniquais mais
surtout ce qu'à perdurer dans les vides
et de trinidad c'est le fameux vide et
du matin qui s'appelle en jour en jour
où vais je sais c'est que c'est quand
même du créole martiniquais
donc moi je pense que effectivement la
martinique est à l'origine du carnaval
de trinidad a lancé vrai que celui ci a
pris un peu plus d'ampleur il en
amérique du sud il a vu ce qui se passe
à rio etc mais je pense que ce l'origine
c'est la martinique celui de lui je ne
dis pas ça très froid mais celui de lui
réussir il faut choisir centré faut pas
dire à nos amis deviennent alors un
dernier mot pour terminer l'émission ils
vont en amont
dire quels sont vos souhaits pour ce
carnaval 2018 comment le voyez-vous
comment le vivrier vous non je crois que
là haut niveau du carnaval les choses
effectivement pris une autre dimension
j'ai l'impression que de plus en plus la
prise de conscience de ce que peut être
ce que peut apporter le carnaval ce
moment de défoulement de liesse et aussi
ce moment de montrer ce qu'on est
capable de faire
prend de plus en plus de sens si bien
qu'à un moment donné une petite décrue
mais quand je vois des beaucoup de
groupes de quartier ils sont une dizaine
à une quinzaine sans organisation
particulière mais avec une créativité
tels que la limiter aux grillages de
chantier devient devient un habile de de
luxe se trouve ça extraordinaire au
niveau des gens qui qui ce sont les
scènes de la vie mais on sent qu'il ya
une recherche et une créativité et si le
canada continue comme ça donc ça veut
dire à la limite on doit vraiment en
aval fric cette année moi je trouve je
trouve que le carnaval
par exemple le fait qu'il y ait des
parades dans chaque commune qui organise
à tour de rôle moi je trouve que la
parade des bêtes à feu là le ccc essai
somptueux c'est magnifique et je pense
que ce genre de manifestation vaf parce
que ça n'existe pas ça peut faire notre
originalité la parade des bêtes à feu le
soir là c'est magnifique
donc ces initiatives là et puis ce
comment dire ce renouvellement de
commune en commune ya pas qu à fort de
france il ya eu à ducos
il y a eu la montée moi je trouve que
c'est ça qui fait la richesse de notre
carnaval et je pense que nous pouvons
faire confiance à nos ânes ou
martiniquais et à nous mêmes merci si
c'est moi que se termine notre émission
donc pour le carnaval avec aujourd'hui
le niveau ce besoin que vous venez
d'entendre directrice des musées de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
et yvan la morandière chef de la mission
carnaval de la ville de fort de france
merci de votre écoute à bientôt bientôt
bientôt merci
face à la première
[Musique]